>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO A SPECIAL EDITION OF
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT."
WHEN WAS THE LAST TIME YOU HEARD
A DEMOCRATIC POLITICIAN PROPOSE
A SOLUTION TO A PROBLEM, NO
MATTER WHAT THE PROBLEM IS, THAT
DIDN'T MAKE THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
MORE POWERFUL?
PONDER THAT FOR A MOMENT.
LET'S SAY FOR EXAMPLE THAT YOU
REALLY BELIEVE GLOBAL WARMING
WAS AN EXISTENTIAL THREAT TO
HUMANITY AND THAT RISING CARBON
DIOXIDE LEVELS WERE CAUSING
GLOBAL WARMING.
WHAT WOULD YOU DO TO FIX IT?
WELL, YOU MIGHT THINK BACK TO
TENTH GRADE BIOLOGY CLASS, CO2,
CO2, HMM, DON'T TREES CONSUME
CO2 FOR PHOTOSYNTHESIS?
QUICK GOOGLE CHECK.
HOW ABOUT WE PLANT A WHOLE LOT
MORE TREES ACROSS THE COUNTRY
AND ACROSS THE WORLD?
THAT SEEMS LIKE A NATURAL
SOLUTION WITH LOTS OF UPSIDE,
TREES ARE BEAUTIFUL, AND MIGHT
HELP FIGHT GLOBAL WARMING.
OH, BUT NO, THERE IS A PROBLEM
WITH THAT IDEA.
PLANTING MORE TREES MIGHT HELP
SOLVE CLIMATE CHANGE, BUT IT
DEFINITELY WILL NOT ENRICH YOUR
DONORS.
TREES ARE CHEAP.
IT IS HARD TO MAKE MONEY FROM
TREES.
WORSE THAN THAT, TREES ARE
IMPOSSIBLE TO REGULATE.
ONCE YOU PLANT TREES, THEY GROW
BY THEMSELVES, THEY DO NOT NEED
FEDERAL HELP.
TREES DEFINITELY WILL NOT MAKE
YOU MORE POWERFUL, SO INSTEAD,
HERE IS AN IDEA, LET'S INVEST
TRILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF OTHER
PEOPLE'S MONEY IN BATTERIES AND
WIND FARMS AND ELECTRIC SCHOOL
BUSES.
THAT WAY DEMOCRATIC POLITICIANS
GET FINGERTIP CONTROL OVER THE
ENTIRE U.S. ECONOMY AND ALL OF
THEIR FRIENDS GET RICH.
SOUNDS PERFECT.
LET'S GO WITH THAT IDEA.
THAT IS HOW DEMOCRATIC
POLITICIANS THINK.
EVERY ONE OF THEM.
SO I PROBABLY SHOULD NOT
SURPRISE YOU THAT
ELIZABETH WARREN HAS A BRAND-NEW
PLAN FOR RISING GAS PRICES, AND
NATURALLY, IT GOES WITHOUT
SAYING, THAT PLAN WOULD GIVE
ELIZABETH WARREN A LOT MORE
CONTROL OVER YOU AND OVER THE
UNITED STATES.
WELL, HOLD ON A MINUTE, YOU MAY
BE WONDERING.
WHY SHOULD ELIZABETH WARREN HAVE
CONTROL OVER ANYTHING?
ELIZABETH WARREN ISN'T VERY
BRIGHT.
SHE HAS NEVER CREATED ANYTHING.
IN FACT, SHE IS A PROVEN LIAR.
THIS IS A PERSON WHO EXPLOITED
THE SUFFERING OF AMERICAN
INDIANS TO GET A JOB PROMOTION.
THE TRAIL OF TEARS MEANS I NEED
10-YEAR.
OKAY.
SO EVERY POSSIBLE WAY,
ELIZABETH WARREN IS MEDIOCRE.
YET, AND HERE'S THE CATCH, SHE
IS ALSO A U.S. SENATOR AND THAT
MEANS SHE HAS POWER.
WARRANTS LATEST PLANT TO MAKE
HERSELF MORE POWERFUL IS THE
PRICE GOUGING PREVENTION ACT OF.
THIS BILL WOULD ALLOW IS OF
ELIZABETH WARREN TO DECIDE WHAT
THINGS COST IN THE
UNITED STATES.
LET'S SAY YOU'RE PAYING $6 A
GALLON FOR GAS, AND YOU MAY BE,
THE OBVIOUS SOLUTION TO THAT --
IN FACT THE ONLY SOLUTION TO
THAT -- IS TO MAKE MORE
GASOLINE.
BECAUSE IF THERE IS MORE OF
SOMETHING, IT WILL COST LESS.
THAT IS NOT JUST BASIC
ECONOMICS, THOUGH IT IS, IT IS
ALSO A LAW OF NATURE.
NEVER CHANGES.
BUT ELIZABETH WARREN WANTS THE
OPPOSITE.
SHE DOES NOT WANT MORE GAS.
IN FACT SHE HAS WORKED HARD TO
PREVENT THE UNITED STATES FOR
PRODUCING MORE GASOLINE, AND
THAT IS THE REASON WHY IT IS SO
EXPENSIVE.
WHAT ELIZABETH WARREN WANTS
INSTEAD IS CONTROL OVER GASOLINE
AND OVER EVERYTHING ELSE, AND
THIS BILL WILL GIVE IT TO HER.
SEE HOW THIS WORKS?
AND THIS IS WHY THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION HAS SHUT DOWN OIL
AND GAS LEASES IN THE MIDDLE OF
AN ENERGY CRISIS.
AND NOT JUST THAT, THEY ARE
CRUSHING REFINERIES.
ACCORDING TO ONE ANALYSIS BY HOT
AIR, "SEVEN AMERICAN REFINERIES
WHICH FORMERLY PROCESSED -- HAVE
GONE OFF-LINE, SOME HAVE SIMPLE
HE SHOT DOWN WHILE OTHERS
WERE BEING CONVERTED TO BIOFUELS
LIKE ETHANOL TO MEET THE DEMANDS
OF THE ENVIRONMENTAL LOBBY.
THESE LOSSES HAVE LEFT THE
UNITED STATES WITH 124 OPERATING
OIL REFINERIES, 10% FEWER
REFINERIES FOR GASOLINE, DIESEL,
JET FUEL THEN WE HAD IN 2016,
EVEN AS DEMAND HAS CONTINUED TO
INCREASE."
DO YOU SEE WHERE THIS IS
GOING.
NO MORE OIL OR GAS FOR YOU, THAT
IS WHY YOU CANNOT AFFORD TO FILL
YOUR TANK.
INSTEAD, THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS DEMANDING
STATES BUILD WIND TURBINES THAT
SOUND GOOD BUT UNFORTUNATELY
DON'T ACTUALLY WORK.
LAST YEAR WE WENT TO TEXAS TO
SEE THIS FIRSTHAND.
HERE'S A CLIP FROM OUR
DOCUMENTARY ON THE TRAGIC
BUFFOONERY OF WIND POWER.
>> WITH NO CHANCE OF BEING
APPROVED NEAR MALIBU OR
GREENWICH OR IN THE MOUNTAINS OF
ASPEN, THE DEVELOPMENT
INVARIABLY HAPPENED IN POORER
PARTS OF THE COUNTRY.
THE NUMBER ONE PLACE FOR
WIND FARMS IS TEXAS.
THE QUESTION IS, WHAT HAPPENS
WHEN THE TURBINES STOP SPINNING?
>> WE ARE IN THE MIDDLE OF
NOWHERE IN TEXAS.
WE ARE TRYING TO FIND A PLACE
JUST TO SLEEP TONIGHT.
EVERYTHING IS SOLD OUT.
THERE IS NOTHING AVAILABLE.
>> IT IS NOW EXPECTED TO BE THE
LARGEST INSURANCE CLAIM EVENT IN
TEXAS HISTORY.
THIS WINTER STORM TOTALLY
OVERWHELMS THE POWER SYSTEM IN
TEXAS.
>> I CAN TELL YOU THIS MORNING,
NEARLY 4.2 MILLION TEXANS STILL
HAVE NO ELECTRICITY.
>> TEXAS HAS THE MOST WIND POWER
CAPACITY IN THE UNITED STATES,
BUT THE TEXAS TURBINES, WHICH
ARE NOT WINTERIZED, ICED UP
DURING A COLD WEATHER EVENT IN
FEBRUARY OF 2021.
ELECTRICITY OUTPUT COLLAPSED.
>> TEXAS REGULATORS ORDERED
ROLLING BLACKOUTS MONDAY AS AN
ARCTIC BLAST HAS FROZEN WIND
TURBINES.
SPEAK OF THE TEXAS GRADE, LIKE
THE CALIFORNIA GRID, IS
BECOMING INCREASINGLY UNRELIABLE
AND DIFFICULT TO MAINTAIN.
DIFFICULT TO KEEP POWER IN A
STEADY BASIS.
>> THIS 20-YEAR-OLD TURBINE IS
LEAKING OIL, DOESN'T LOOK TOO
GREEN TO ME.
>> Tucker: SO THE POINT OF AN
ENERGY GRID IS TO PRODUCE AND
TRANSMIT ENERGY.
IT HAS ONLY ONE PURPOSE, AND
THAT PURPOSE IS BEING SABOTAGED
ON PURPOSE BY THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION AND BY
WALL STREET IN FAVOR OF GREEN
ENERGY, IN FAVOR OF WINDMILLS
THAT DON'T ACTUALLY WORK, AND AS
A RESULT OF THAT WE ARE FACING A
PROSPECT OF MORE BLACKOUTS THIS
SUMMER.
WE DON'T HAVE ELECTRICITY
ANYMORE.
IT'S A FIRST WORLD COUNTRY.
BUT ELIZABETH ONE HAS A FIX FOR
THAT.
"IT SHALL BE UNLAWFUL FOR A
PERSON TO SELL OR OFFER FOR SALE
A GOOD OR SERVICES AT AN
UNCONSCIONABLY EXCESSIVE PRICE
DURING EXCEPTIONAL MARKET SHOCK
REGARDLESS OF THE PERSONS
POSITION IN THE SUPPLY CHAIN OR
DISTRIBUTION NETWORK."
SO THE ARGUMENT HERE FROM
ELIZABETH WARREN'S ARGUMENT, THE
ECONOMY HAS BEEN IN A PERIOD OF
EXCEPTIONAL MARKET SHOCK THE
PANDEMIC BEGAN.
THEREFORE, PRICES SET BY EVERY
INDUSTRY ACROSS THE COUNTRY
WOULD FALL UNDER THE REGULATORY
AUTHORITY OF WHO?
ELIZABETH WARREN.
MOST OF THE PRICE GOUGING BILLS
ARE LIMITED TO SPECIFIC AREAS
DURING NATURAL DISASTERS BUT
THIS ONE IS NOT, IT IS
ECONOMY-WIDE AND FOREVER.
THE QUESTION IS HOW EXACTLY DOES
ELIZABETH WARREN DEFINE
"UNCONSCIONABLY EXCESSIVE
PRICES," BECAUSE THEY ARE NOT
DEFINED IN THE LEGISLATION?
SO IT TURNS OUT THE DEFINITION
IS UP TO, CAN YOU GUESS,
ELIZABETH WARREN.
ANY BUSINESS WITH GROSS ANNUAL
REVENUES OVER $100,000 A YEAR,
THAT MEANS PRETTY MUCH EVERYBODY
IN THE COUNTRY, MUST NOW OBEY
ELIZABETH WARREN.
THAT MEANS ELIZABETH WARREN, WHO
HAD THE POWER TO SET THE PRICE
OF SAY DIESEL FUEL, THAT IS WHAT
WE USE TO FUEL TRUCKS FOR
EVERYTHING YOU BUY OR CONSUME,
THEY TEND TO ENTIRE U.S. ECONOMY
DEPENDS ON DIESEL.
CVS REPORTED DECENTLY PRICES ARE
GETTING TO THE POINT WHERE
TRUCKERS CAN'T WORK ANYMORE.
WATCH.
>> KILL PRICES LIKE $6.39 A
GALLON.
>> IMAGINE PAYING THAT FOR A
FILL UP OF MORE THAN
100 GALLONS.
>> A REGULAR FILL UP WOULD HAVE
BEEN, JUST A SIX MONTH, ABOUT
$700.
NOW, IT'S ABOUT 1,000.
>> IT IS WHAT TRUCKERS ARE
FACING ACROSS THE COUNTRY FOR
DIESEL, AND YOU ARE PAYING THE
PRICE, ACCORDING TO OIL ANALYST
TOM CLUES OUT.
SPEAK WITH YOU'RE ORDERING
ORDERING ANYTHING THAT MOVED BY
FREIGHT OR ACROSS THE COUNTRY, T
COMES VIA THE FUEL
SURCHARGES, PROBABLY NOT THE
WORST OF THE DIESEL SURCHARGES,
THAT WILL COME NEXT MONTH.
I JUST DON'T THINK THERE IS ANY
MAGIC BULLET AT THE MOMENT.
IT'S GOING TO BE TOUGH.
IT IS GOING TO BE A TOUGH
SUMMER.
>> Tucker: SO MOST PROJECTIONS
SUGGEST THIS -- AND BY "THIS,"
WE MEAN THE PRICE OF ENERGY, IS
GOING TO GET WORSE, AND THAT IS
EXACTLY WHAT ELIZABETH ONE IS
COUNTING ON, YOU'RE
SUFFERING.
SHE HOPES AMERICANS GET SO
DESPERATE THAT THEY GO TO HER TO
SET THE PRICE OF DIESEL AS WELL
AS EVERYTHING BOUGHT OR SOLD IN
THE UNITED STATES ECONOMY AND
WHEN THAT HAPPENS, WHAT
HAPPENS?
INTERESTING QUESTION, SO AT THIS
POINT, A LOT OF MONEY IS
FLOATING AROUND THE U.S. ECONOMY
AND THAT IS BECAUSE OF
GOVERNMENT SPENDING.
THE FEDERAL RESERVE PRINTS
MONEY, GOES TO THE BANKS, AND
THEN IT FILTERS DOWN TO
WALL STREET AND THEY BUY BIGGER
HOUSES.
AND AT THE SAME TIME, SUPPLIES
OF ESSENTIAL GOODS ARE VERY
LIMITED SO WHEN YOU IMPOSE PRICE
CONTROLS IN THAT KIND OF
ENVIRONMENT, ANYONE, ANYONE?
BIDDING WAR STARTED AND PRICES
GO UP EVEN HIGHER.
AS THE ECONOMY ALAN COLE PUT IT
RECENTLY, YOU WILL INEVITABLY
GET A SCALPERS PARADISE.
GOVERNMENT IMPOSED PRICES WILL
BE LOW, SO THEY WILL SELL OUT
FAST, OF COURSE, AND THEN YOU
GET A BLACK MARKET.
WE DON'T HAVE TO GUESS, BECAUSE
THIS HAS HAPPENED IN EVERY
CONTROLLED ECONOMY IN HISTORY,
THE BOLSHEVIKS LEARNED THIS
EARLY WHEN THEY IMPOSE PRICE
CONTROLS.
SO WHAT DO YOU DO NEXT IF YOUR
GOVERNMENT IMPOSING THESE?
YOU CRACKDOWN ON SCALPERS, THAT
IS WHAT ELIZABETH WARREN'S BILL
WOULD DO.
SO YOU GET A LOT MORE
LAW ENFORCEMENT, A LOT OF PEOPLE
GOING TO JAIL, BUT YOU ALSO GET
WITH THE ECONOMIST GREGORY
GROSSMAN CALLS THE SECOND
ECONOMY, PEOPLE DO ANYTHING THEY
CAN TO GET THE GOVERNMENT
APPROVED A LOWER PRICE.
THE SOVIETS TRADED FAVORS AN
ESTABLISHED PROTECTION, THEY
CALLED THE SYSTEM -- WHICH
TRANSLATED FROM POLISH MEANT
SOMEONE WHO PROVIDES COVER.
WHAT YOU GET IS CORRUPTION.
CORRUPTION IS THE INEVITABLE
RESULT OF PRICE CONTROLS.
EVEN THE SOVIETS LEARNED THIS
AFTER ALMOST 70 YEARS.
IT IS WHY GORBACHEV OF BANDED
PRICE CONTROLS IN THE 1990s.
NICOLAS MADURO, A PRETTY
RIGOROUS MARXIST, ALSO ABANDONED
PRICE CONTROLS IN VENEZUELA.
WHAT HE DID THAT THREE YEARS
AGO.
IN THE 1970s, RICHARD NIXON
ALSO REALIZED, CAN YOU IMAGINE,
PRICE CONTROLS DON'T WORK, BUT
ONLY AFTER HE FROZE ALL PRICES
AND WAGES IN UNITED STATES, AND
THAT EVENTUALLY LED TO A MASSIVE
SPIKE IN DEMAND AND DOUBLE-DIGIT
INFLATION.
SO PEOPLE WHO DON'T UNDERSTAND
BASIC ECONOMIC PRINCIPLES
PROBABLY SHOULD NOT FULL AROUND
WITH THE ECONOMY, BUT THEY CAN
NEVER CONTROL THEMSELVES, AND
THAT IS WHY SOME OF THE BIGGEST
FIGURES IN THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
RIGHT NOW WANT TO REPEAT
MISTAKES WE HAVE SEEN COUNTLESS
TIMES, NOT JUST
ELIZABETH WARREN.
IT IS THE SUPPOSEDLY MODERATE
BOB CASEY, SHELDON WHITEHOUSE,
WHO IS NOT VERY BRIGHT, AND
BERNIE SANDERS AND ED MARKEY AND
JEFF MERKLEY AND TAMMY DUCKWORTH
AND DIANNE FEINSTEIN, THEY ARE
ALL ON BOARD WITH THIS BILL, AND
THEN IN THE HOUSE YOU HAVE
JERRY NADLER, DAVID SISSON NINI
OF RHODE ISLAND, THE FORMER MOB
LAWYER, KATIE PORTER OF
CALIFORNIA, RO KHANNA,
SILICON VALLEY -- THEY HAVE ALL
CLOSE COSPONSOR LEGISLATION.
THERE HOPING IF THEY DO THAT YOU
WON'T OPEN WIKIPEDIA TO FIND OUT
WHAT HAPPENED WITH EVERY OTHER
COUNTRY IN THE HISTORY TRIED
THIS.
THEY DEFINITELY DON'T WANT YOU
LOOKING AT THE HISTORY OF THE
SOVIET UNION AND THAT IS WHY
THAT HISTORY IS NO LONGER TAUGHT
IN SCHOOLS.
INSTEAD, THEY WANT YOU TO WATCH
REPORTS LIKE THIS AND IN FEAR
GIVE THEM TOTAL CONTROL OVER
YOUR ECONOMY.
>> THE SHIFTING AND SHRINKING
SCHOOL LUNCH MENU.
SUPPLY CHAIN DISRUPTIONS AND THE
SPIRALING COST OF KEY
INGREDIENTS HAS FORCED SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO PULL BACK OR MAKE
SUBSTITUTIONS.
AT SOME SCHOOLS, NO MORE
HAMBURGERS OR CHICKEN PATTY
SANDWICHES DUE TO PROBLEMS AND
THE PRICE OF BUYING BONDS AND
KETCHUP, A NEW SERVICE OF SCHOOL
DISTRICTS NATIONWIDE REVEALS 97%
OF MEAL PROGRAMS REPORTED
CHALLENGES WITH HIGHER COSTS,
WHILE 98% ACKNOWLEDGE PROBLEMS
GETTING SOME MENU ITEMS.
THE SUPPLIES AND THE
INGREDIENTS, COSTS ARE POISED TO
RISE AGAIN FOR YOUR SCHOOL'S
JULY 1ST, WHEN AN EMERGENCY
MEASURE AND ACTED AT THE START
OF THE PANDEMIC EXPIRES.
>> Tucker: SO WE ARE NOT
SHILLING FOR BIG BUSINESS HERE,
WE DO NOT WORK FOR JOE BIDEN.
WE DON'T HAVE TO.
IN FACT, WE ARE OFTEN NIGHTLY
CRITICAL OF BIG BUSINESS.
BUT LET'S BE HONEST FOR A
SECOND.
DOES ANY SERIOUS PERSON ACTUALLY
BELIEVE THAT HAMBURGER AND
CHICKEN PATTY MANUFACTURERS ARE
HOLDING BACK SUPPLIES OF THEIR
PRODUCTS BECAUSE THEY ARE
GREEDY?
[LAUGHS]
THAT IS NOT WHAT IS HAPPENING.
WE WISH IT WERE WHAT IS
HAPPENING, BECAUSE YOU COULD
PROBABLY FIX THAT.
BUT THAT IS WHAT THEY ARE
TELLING YOU IS HAPPENING, AND
THEY ARE TELLING YOU THAT SO
YOU'LL BELIEVE IT.
THEY WANT YOU TO BELIEVE THAT
THE BABY FORMULA SHORTAGE IS NOT
ABOUT SUPPLY, IT IS ABOUT
PRICING.
UNFORTUNATELY, THAT IS JUST NOT
TRUE.
HERE IS NBC WITH THE LATEST
FIGURES ON THE SHORTAGE.
>> THE FDA TELLING NBC NEWS IT
IS CONCERNED, NOT HAVING CERTAIN
FORMULAS AVAILABLE ON SHELVES
COULD POSE LIFE-THREATENING
RISKS FOR INFANT.
ONE MOM SAYS SHE HAS BEEN
GRAPPLING WITH THE SHORTAGE FOR
TWO MONTHS, AFTER THEIR FORMULA
WAS RECALLED.
>> HOW ARE YOU DEALING?
>> I AM JUST REALLY TAKING IT
DAY BY DAY, TO BE HONEST.
>> UNABLE TO FIND HER FORMULA ON
SHELVES, SHE HAD NO CHOICE BUT
TO SUDDENLY SWITCH BRANDS.
TEXAS HAS BEEN HIT PARTICULARLY
HARD.
THE FORMULA OUT OF STOCK RATE
HERE IS NOW 50% HERE.
>> Tucker: OH, SO THE KEY LINE
WAS THE LAST LINE, THE OUT OF
STOCK RATE IS NOW 50%.
SO THEY JUST DON'T HAVE THE
PRODUCT.
COMPANIES GENERALLY IF THEY HAVE
A PRODUCT ARE EAGER TO SELL THE
PRODUCT BECAUSE THEY ARE IN THE
BUSINESS OF SELLING PRODUCTS TO
MAKE MONEY.
BUT UNFORTUNATELY IF YOU HAVE NO
GROUNDING IN ECONOMICS AT ALL,
NOT EVEN THEORETICAL, BUT
PRACTICAL, LIKE IF YOUR WHOLE
LIFE HAS CONSISTED OF LYING TO
LARGE CROWDS GET ELECTED TO
PRINT MORE MONEY TO PAY
YOURSELF, GIVE YOURSELF THE MOST
GENEROUS RETIREMENT IN THE
UNITED STATES, YOU PROBABLY
DON'T KNOW HOW ANYTHING WORKS.
AND THAT WOULD DESCRIBE MOST
LEADERS IN THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
SO THEIR SOLUTION, NOT
SURPRISINGLY, IS OF THE
SOLUTION.
IT WILL MAKE THE PROBLEM WORSE,
BUT IT WILL MAKE THEM MORE
POWERFUL.
, DO YOU NOT LIKE THAT?
OH, WE ARE SORRY.
WE WOULD LOVE TO